to you you fine people i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
today is october 18 2021 and if you
would like to chat live during the show
you can do so at rubenreport.locals.com
that's on the desktop or you can
download the locals app we've got one
for ios we've got one for android and
then you can chat with other viewers as
we're doing this you might be able to
submit questions live or if you make a
pithy comment or a fact check you can
fact check me live in the chat and my
assistant helen is in the chat right now
talking to you fine people she can
communicate directly using an electronic
device to my producer michael right here
and then he can alert me of the
information that you're dropping
live
right here on youtube that
is incredible technology people can you
believe it
i have to say that mondays often are my
favorite show of the week because you
know we get all the nonsense from the
sunday news shows that are you know sort
of not being watched much anymore but
that's where all the politicians go and
that's where all the media elite sort of
get their stories from the week so we
can sort of really like pack in a whole
bunch of lies on sunday that then guys
like me have to uh communicate the lies
expose and communicate the lies to you
guys on monday so mondays it's like
there's never a shortage of stuff to
talk about so we've got four stories for
you today first off uh openly homosexual
uh transportation secretary pete bootage
and i only say that he's openly
homosexual because that's the only
reason he got the job that's pretty much
what they told us it was a diversity
hire he has no experience do anything
doing anything in the transportation
sector uh he was on one of the sunday
shows telling us that everything's great
there's just nothing to worry about the
economy's great the supply chain it's
all fine you people are nuts it's all
good so we'll talk about that then this
biden fella he's the old guy pretending
to be president uh he was at a
restaurant over the weekend and you're
not gonna believe it wasn't wearing a
mask yeah you're supposed to wear masks
indoors uh he wasn't so you know is he
infected quarantines what are we talking
about people uh then we've got two
really great videos on this fouchy guy
you know fauci mr i'm whatever you want
me to be on any given day uh well he has
more thoughts on what we're allowed to
do for the holidays this year including
uh halloween thanksgiving and christmas
and then we've got an incredible this
thing went viral and i just had to put
it up for you guys an incredible
compilation video of him talking about
vaccines and how well they work and how
that has changed over time they went
from 100
and well we all sort of know where
they're at at the moment and then
finally because i've been trying to give
you guys some white pill stuff like
where's the hope right where's the hope
in the distance well a new study has
come out and it turns out that americans
for the first time in a long long time
actually want less government pretty
spectacular it's like oh people are
starting to realize that the elites
don't really care about you and no more
no matter how much money you give them
or they take from you uh they don't make
anything better so uh we are going to
discuss all that but let's start with
gay transportation secretary pete
bootage he is a very serious man who is
mayor of a small town and then became
transportation secretary because they
wanted a diversity hire and he is gay
and by the way i have no problems with
gay people my husband's gay and uh
pete went on one of the sunday shows to
talk about supply chain issues here's
pete well certainly a lot of the
challenges that we've been experiencing
this year will continue into next year
but there are both short-term and
long-term steps that we can take to do
something about it look uh part of
what's happening isn't just the supply
side it's the demand side demand is off
the charts retail sales are through the
roof and if you think about those images
of
ships for example waiting at anchor on
the west coast you know every one of
those ships
is full of record amounts of goods that
americans are buying because demand is
up because income is up because the
president has successfully guided this
economy out of the teeth of a terrifying
recession
all right pete let's talk um first off
you have a bit of that affect that just
reads as everything you're saying is off
a teleprompter and you don't even
believe it he's got a little bit of that
sake thing going there like he's just
giving you these statements that aren't
really meaningless yeah the economy is
so great and so many people are buying
so much stuff that that's why you can't
get stuff does that sound right to any
of you anyone watching this please
somebody reach through the computer and
grab my neck and choke me if i'm wrong
on this one does that seem right that
what we're all feeling right now is the
economy is so freaking great we've all
got so much money we're all so secure in
our jobs in the future of this country
and the market seems strong and all of
those things that we're all buying so
much stuff that that's why they can't
get stuff to us that's what he's saying
no
we just know it's not true this thing is
sort of hanging on by a thread right it
feels like a house of cards that's like
starting to wobble and there's the guy
the magician they're going oh no no
everything's gonna be okay everything's
gonna be okay so i wanted to test what
pete said there that it's just because
people want to buy things so literally a
minute before the show you can see the
time stamps right there i think it was
six minutes before the show to be
technical those are screenshots that
you're seeing
off my telephone my iphone and i went in
and i wanted to buy a couch and i
thought i'll try west elm i will try cb2
and crane barrel because i told you guys
we've been trying to buy a couch for a
while and there are these long delays so
i just picked the first couch on each of
these sites and then i picked purchase
just to see the delivery dates west elm
if you were to get one of their couches
right now february 3rd to 7th
3rd to the 17th cb2 end of january crate
and barrel mid may i did not do this in
some duplicitous way i literally just
picked the first couch on each one that
popped up when i did the search with the
store name and couch okay
now the question is is pete right is it
because so many people are buying
couches now there's never been more
couches being bought that for the first
time in modern memory it's taking five
six seven months to get a couch or could
it be
that there's a problem at warehouses and
we're laying off all sorts of people and
then there's this vaccine mandate thing
and some people don't want to go to jobs
that are going to force them to be
injected with things or a series of
other things like the government giving
money for people to stay unemployed
which is why this weekend when i
virtually never leave my house anymore
in this craptastic city of los angeles
we were gonna go somewhere not even
gonna say where we were gonna go
somewhere and i had to cancel my uber
because it was going to take 22 minutes
for the uber to come to me because they
can't even get uber drivers anymore is
this all a sign of the economy is so
great that people don't have to work at
uber anymore or is it a sign that
nobody's working because of unemployment
and a series of other things including
mandates and everything else so pete's
just lying like they're just lying but
but don't take my word for just ask
around
talk to your friends talk to your
business manager talk to your accountant
talk to your employees does everyone
just feel like it's really really great
and that's the problem because we're all
buying so much stuff right now or is
something else going on i tend
to think it is something else and yes it
is true conor by the way my husband is
gay
uh all right story number two joe biden
he's the elderly man pretending to be
president of the united states and we
know he puts on masks when he's doing
certain speeches but then when he walks
up and talks to little children after he
takes the mask off he usually sniffs
their hair there was another video of
that this weekend too we didn't even
want to show it to you it's just so
gross uh but you know the things just
become complete and ridiculous theater
well joe biden went to eat with dr jill
biden and she's a doctor so she would
know about the efficacy of masks they
went to eat at a very very exclusive
very expensive restaurant in dc where
you know when you're walking to your
table as you know to be a good safe
american you have to put your mask on
well when joe was leaving he wasn't
wearing his mask here's nine seconds of
videotape
there's no audio on it so there's joe
and there's there he is and he's holding
his mask and you saw dr jill and you
know their lackeys are behind them and
they're wearing the masks anyway it's
not that this is just such a big deal
but it's like joe is not afraid of
catching kobet i don't know how many
booster shots he's had and all of that
stuff he's 78 years old you would think
in a public place the most powerful man
in the united states would be very
cautious wouldn't the doctor
you know the white house doctor be
telling him exactly what to do wouldn't
his secret uh secret service guys you
know wouldn't they be like uh mr
president you forgot to put your mask on
not only is it a violation of the dc
regulation so you're going to get fined
a thousand dollars which i'd love to see
if biting it's fine a thousand dollars
not only you're going to get fined or i
guess the restaurant tour gets fined a
thousand dollars not the patron so we'll
find out about that um
but you know you probably optics-wise
probably wouldn't be the best thing so
somebody there took video of them and
that's what a good citizen does because
these people don't care they do not
believe in their rules and i don't even
think joe biden really believes that
covet is real at this point i i think
that if he did that at his
age
and everything else they would be taking
no risks but we played the video last
week where biden and dr jill
walk out of the helicopter and they have
their masks on with their assistant and
the assistants walking with the mess
then she takes the mask off and it's
like you obviously all weren't wearing
the mask in the helicopter like we know
all of this stuff here's a little more a
little more from the post-millennial on
this on saturday night president joe
biden was caught maskless dining with
first lady jill biden inside the upscale
fiola mare restaurant in washington d.c
an apparent violation of the district's
indoor mask mandate dc still requires
all indoor diners to wear a mask unless
they're actively eating and drinking the
president was filmed walking around
without a mask when greeted by reporters
and by the public outside biden was met
with cheers and a sole question of how
was dinner mr president no reporters
questioned his lack of masking so look
you guys know this is all theater and
and dribble and nonsense and has very
little to do with anyone getting sick or
not the idea that we go into restaurants
and when you sit at a table somehow
you're not going to catch covet but when
you go to the bathroom you should put a
mask on or when you're not actively
eating and drinking which is also what
they do on airplanes sitting somehow i
guess covid you know goes around five
foot seven is the average what's the
average height of a human being can i
get an average height of a human being
let's say about five 8 something like
that
the covet must be floating around at
that level when you sit
what do we got what do we got when you
sit covered can't hit you i mean all of
these nonsensical things and biden knows
as mangled and marbled as his brain is
biden even knows that it's all sort of
nonsense uh the average height of a man
five foot six that is short that is oh
connor's very excited about that
congratulations mr average and the
average height of a woman five foot two
so i guess if you're above five foot six
you know if people are breathing so if
you're five eight then why do you have
to wear a mask because they're breathing
it's going this way
you can walk right past them anyway it's
all just it's all just theater and
nonsense and speaking of theater and
nonsense hell of a segway we've got some
fouchy stuff for you so fauci
again was making the rounds on sunday
you'd think that this man in this
pandemic that's getting worse and
everyone's dying and we must destroy
everything in the name of safety and all
that you would think that fauci wouldn't
have time on sunday to you know be going
all these shows you'd think that they'd
have somebody else doing the pr
you know he's old also how old is he's
about 80 years old i think he might be
81 years old if i'm not mistaken you'd
think that they'd have other people out
there do running the public space of
this because he'd be in there you know
like in the lab doing the science thing
and he'd have the thing and he'd be you
know splicing dna and combining things
and all that stuff that scientists do
he's 80 years old um well no he still
spends all his sundays doing all of
these uh sunday talk shows and here he
had some advice on what we can do if
we're good vaccinated citizens in the
upcoming holiday season
and dr fanshee lastly we know the best
way to keep safe is to be vaccinated but
what are your guidelines for the
upcoming holidays will you be giving out
halloween candy what do we do
thanksgiving christmas and the other
holidays
well martha i believe strongly that
particularly in the vaccinated people if
you're vaccinated and your family
members are vaccinated those who are
eligible and that is obviously very
young children are not yet eligible that
you can enjoy the holidays you can enjoy
halloween
trick-or-treating and certainly
thanksgiving with your family and
christmas with your families that's one
of the reasons why we emphasize
why it's so important to get vaccinated
not only for your own safety for that of
your family but also for the good of the
community to keep the level of infection
down when you do that there's no reason
at all why you can't enjoy the holidays
in a family way the way we've
traditionally done it all along
yeah you know enjoying the holidays in a
family way the way we've done all along
really has nothing to do with listening
to people like him i get it he's
probably not a horrible person i don't
know what's going on with him at this
point like do i think he's a satan
worshiper and he's trying to destroy the
west possibly but i'm not fully saying
that i don't know what's going on with
this man i really don't
but if we are to believe that the
vaccines work let's say you want to go
home well i talked about halloween last
week because last week he had already
said you can do halloween so you know
we're allowed to go to strangers doors
they were telling us you know six foot
social distancing and you've got to
spray down your shopping bags and
everything else now you're allowed to go
to a stranger's door and take candy from
them okay and we know that people just
eat the candy right then the kids are
eating it but okay now that's okay right
even though as he said the youngest kids
aren't vaccinated of course what he
didn't say is that virtually no kids
have died of covid it's about 500 kids
point zero zero two percent there's a
lot of evidence to show that those
numbers are even inflated and that they
had all sorts of other things that's not
diminish any of their lives okay got it
um but now uh we can do thanksgiving but
let's think about it let's think about
it this way thanksgiving rolls around
let's he's saying if everyone's
vaccinated you're good to go well let's
say you have 10 people for thanksgiving
right and let's say you've got a crazy
right wing
freedom-loving libertarian don't tread
on me
cousin
right and that guy shows up and he's
probably smiling and he probably takes
care of himself too and he knows that
he's healthy and he shows up and i get
it he's right wing and he loves freedom
and america
and he probably sent a couple bucks to
rand paul you know like this is some nut
bag but you know he shows up and he's a
pretty decent guy and now you've all
been vaccinated
why
would we think that he
would get everyone sick if you've all
been vaccinated can someone please
explain that to me i'm not a scientician
i'm not pretending that i'm one but can
someone explain that to me now first off
just because you aren't vaccinated it
doesn't mean you automatically have
covid that seems to be the new thing
that only vaccinated people can do
things but you're telling me that
otherwise young healthy people can't do
the things that they've always done
how does that make any sense i mean this
is exactly what kyrie irving the
basketball player is talking about
jonathan isaac from the nba these guys
who are saying hey i'm young and healthy
like let's just go about living our
lives right was coveted spread at any
nba games they haven't shown us any
evidence of that but when he says that
everyone has to be vaccinated for you to
get together it's like you don't care
about families anthony fauci you don't
care about personal choice you don't
care that people might take their age
and health and all of those things into
account what you care about is you want
to say something and have
the minions do it
and you're not a king you're not even an
elected official you know like
i think people are just going to go and
do what they want and by the way when
when i say that do what you want it's
like
first off you should do what you want
you shouldn't listen to me other than
i'm trying to talk about freedom a
little bit which i know is a very scary
word it's the f word now you know and
it's like
you should take into account whether you
have a grandmother who's very old or
someone else in your family that's very
infirmed with something and all of those
things but again if the vaccines are to
work and they told us a hundred percent
they told us biden said once you're
vaccinated get out there live your life
and all that that was back in may june
and that is a perfect segue to this next
compilation video that's going making
the rounds on twitter so this is
spectacular you really need to watch
this we're going to show you about 80
seconds of it i think
it's about a two and a half minute video
of the full thing but we wanted to cut
it a little bit for brevity saying here
this is over time
watching how fauchy
talked about the efficacy of vaccines it
was a hundred percent up until where
it's at now so watch this it's it's
really really well done do we know who
made this because i want to credit them
properly we'll try to find it and put it
in the in the description uh it's really
spectacular
so now we have two vaccines that are
really quite effective the mrna vaccine
highly effective extraordinarily
efficacious 94 to 95 percent for mild to
moderate disease and
virtually 100 percent efficacious
because the real world effectiveness
is even more impressive than the results
of the clinical trial
[Music]
you might need another shot we've got to
make sure we clarify that with people it
has nothing to do whether or not it's
effective we know it's highly effective
highly
i mean tell me that's just not
spectacular and that's why these people
want to censor the internet right like
that is exactly why they don't want us
to be able to make videos like that and
share videos like that by the way we did
we were able to source it it's at mv
heal h-e-a-l
on twitter so bravo to whoever that
account is run by what's incredible
about that is you can see he's going
from 100 and then the headlines start
coming out it's 94 it's 88 and they did
it in chronological order i mean you
should watch it again then it's 88 then
it's 81 then it's 55 then it's 47. and
then of course as it ends there japan's
suspending uh certain vaccination use
moderna being suspended in certain
countries by the way we know right now
that in several of the nordic countries
i think sweden denmark maybe some of the
others they're completely open now and
they've decided you don't have to have
vaccine passports and anything else so
you would think that our brilliant young
socialist minds here in this country
like aoc would be saying that we should
be doing it like those nordic countries
because she's always telling us how
great they are they're so freaking
wonderful they're also tiny homogenous
countries um which were you know
basically one skin color until the last
couple years and now they've got some
other problems but that doesn't really
fit aoc's thing um but it's just a great
video because it's just a perfect
example of how we forget things doesn't
it feel like we consistently
forget what happened not even a month
ago
forget a year and a half ago forget two
weeks to flatten the curve right it
would be absurd for him ever to say that
straight statement now why doesn't you
want a real journalist to be out there
or without you you want to do this show
that would be my first question when you
guys said two weeks to flatten the curve
what did you mean by that and did we not
do it are the numbers worse than you
would have wanted the flattened curve to
be two weeks later compared to now and
if they are worse then obviously
something else is very very wrong
at best you people are completely
negligent at worst your homicidal
maniacs
that's why he doesn't get asked any of
those questions right it's just a big
sort of
circular it's basically a giant circle
jerk between incompetent government
buffoons and their ridiculous media
cohorts that that really is what goes on
on these sunday shows oh you got
everything wrong and i'll ask you the
questions to cover up your thing so that
we can all keep going and people will
keep watching and i'll keep getting paid
and you'll stay in your job forever and
we'll do this
yeah let's keep doing it to that point
though it brings us to story number four
because this is some white pill good
news people are waking up to this stuff
crazy dave rubin
and his crazy crew of youtube blaze tv
locals viewers have imparted some wisdom
on the masses it's possible because
people are starting to realize that the
federal government is too powerful and
doesn't do much good so we've got some
info this is a new gallup poll a quote
from blaze media a new survey from
gallup finds that most americans have
reverted to thinking the government
should have a more limited role last
september when the nation was firmly in
the grips of the coronavirus pandemic
with states locked down businesses
closed and racial unrest dominating
headlines a record high 54 percent of
u.s adults surveyed by gallup said the
government should do more to solve
problems but in the years since then
president joe biden took office and
started a massive expansion of the
federal government's role in the
pandemic response on constitutional
executive orders vaccine mandates 1.9
million a trillion dollar stimulus bill
one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
and a 3.5 build back better spending
bill now gallup finds that 52 percent of
americans say the government is doing
too many things that should be left to
the individuals and businesses while 43
say the government needs to do more to
solve problems so we're going to throw
this image up for just a second the key
part that you have to look at there
i've got it in front of me right here
too is that the blue line which is that
the government should do more to solve
problems if you look just right at the
end there it was peaking it was peaking
basically in 2020 we were all freaked
out we wanted the government to do stuff
well now it's dumping out we're
realizing the government doesn't do much
well and the green line which says the
government's trying to do too many
things well that jumped from 41 about a
year ago to 52 now this is a great sign
this is the type of sign that we have
needed to see that people are realizing
it's your life the machine doesn't
really work it doesn't really care about
you it wants to control you they flaunt
their own rules joe biden at a
restaurant in dc this week you can keep
giving them your money and getting less
and less for it or you can start
thinking about your life seriously
trying to figure out ways
to flourish without
needing these ridiculous buffoons
that's actually very much what my next
book is about which comes out in april
we'll have a little more on the exact
launch date and everything else soon you
can pre-order don't burn this country at
don't burn this country.com i was not
planning to do a commercial there but it
does work uh all right guys i've enjoyed
this monday show how do you feel about
it thumbs up you thumbs up
what are you 5'6 again
by now it's 5 10 okay you're sitting all
day i don't know what you're doing over
there uh part one of my interview with
lauren bobert who is a congressman from
colorado's third district congresswoman
i should say well i'll leave that to her
but uh
um
she she's really really super
interesting and she's one of this young
crop of republicans sort of like in the
dan crenshaw uh vane who people really
should know about you know you've got
the squad you've got these horrible
out-of-control hysterical anti-american
congresswomen from the left the
progressives like aoc and ohan omar and
rashida talib and corey bush these
really just anti-american people but
they're in the media all the time
they're on the front page of everything
all the time i had a great chat with
lauren bobert like just a great chat she
is a decent person who is treated
horribly by the media and for the first
time ever in a reuben report interview
live in studio uh clyde burst into the
studio he actually opened the door like
a velociraptor in jurassic park he
opened the door and burst in so we left
it and it's in the full and i tweeted
out a little clip of it that you can see
this morning uh i thank those of you who
uh
played along at reubenreport.locals.com
do we have one particular comment maybe
that yeah we've got something give me
something here that the people were
saying in the live chat that's how we're
going to end the shows for now on with
at least one commentary or question or
something we've got a question here uh
uncle bob's coffee you know we usually
do the q and a's on thursdays but i like
this idea like one question or comment
at the end of the show uh dave do you
think we will ever get back to the
original intent of the constitution or
are we too far gone i think some states
will get back to it and some states
won't
what i've been trying to explain to
people about the progressives is there's
no logic or reason or rule or law
from the past that they care about so if
you were to say to any of these members
of the progressive caucus or even to
your to your most progressive friends
you know the way the constitution works
is we have three branches of government
and one rights laws and one passes them
one makes the sure that they're legal
etc etc that's checks and balances like
they don't care about that ask them if
they care about it they don't because
they would tell you that's a patriarchal
system designed by racists to oppress
certain people and something about white
supremacy etc they don't care about
those rules
some of us do i actually think most of
us do and i think more and more of us
will come to
appreciate those rules because as things
continue to get worse no matter what
pete buda judge tells you as the wheels
continue to spin off the big government
machine and the blue states go more and
more bananas uh more and more people
will see that and they'll be like oh you
know those
those old rules that old piece of paper
those documents that freed us and you
know really created this incredible
machine that we've been living in for
250 years you know that was pretty good
maybe we should get back to that so what
i think is going to happen
is something that i've talked about
quite a bit but i think it's in many
ways what the founders intended with the
federalist system some states are just
going to go their own way i'm not
calling for civil war obviously
but florida
texas tennessee some of these states are
just going to keep i hope saying you
know what we're just not going to worry
that much about what the feds do we're
just not going to you know we're going
to do what's right here in our states
and some states won't do that right like
california i think will be the sort of
leading kind of
laboratory for the for the far left
lunacy that they're going to try to
export throughout the nation which by
the way is exactly what gavin newsom and
joe biden said during our ridiculous
recall election here so are we ever
going to get back to it it depends where
you live it depends where you live
but
the worse and worse and more hysterical
that they get
the more that they wake us up somebody
who is that leia woman who said
something like that about star systems
slipping through the fingers
grandma tarkin i haven't done a star
wars reference in a while you got it you
see what i'm saying the more that they
try to grab us the more we'll wake up
that's how it works all right guys i
enjoy this 28 minutes today not bad
uh have a nice week i think uh i i send
some good stuff you know that's where
i'm at where are you let me know at
rubin report.locals.com see you tomorrow